guys i'm sorry because  this is such a massive difference no  matter what you're doing how much better  is the new 16-inch m1 pro macbook  compared to the previous intel 16-inch  that it directly replaces  [Music]  apple managed to make it even better  this is the intel 16-inch macbook pro  this is the new 16-inch macbook pro we  have 30 more pixels than with the  previous 16 inch it goes up to 120 hertz  but it can actually slow down to 24  hertz it can also reach up to a thousand  it's sustained and 1600 peak and when we  turn on some hdr content i mean you guys  can see the difference here i have  lightroom opened up right here this took  three minutes and 47 seconds compared to  one minute and 23 seconds looking at the  intel system we are now at five percent  battery the new 16 inch is that 52  battery life